on this episode of Imagine a world my
best is that Adriana will progress much
more slowly than I have it progressing
in my story and my best guess is that we
do survive because AGI progresses much
more slowly from my perspective it's
extremely contrived for AGI to develop
even as fast as it does in this story
and be handled well enough cautiously
enough thoughtfully enough that we have
more than a fraction of a percent chance
of survival
welcome to imagine a world a mini series
from the future of Life Institute this
podcast is based on a contest we ran to
gather ideas from around the world about
what a more positive future might look
like in 2045
we hope the diverse ideas you're about
to hear will spark discussions and maybe
even collaborations but you should know
that the ideas in this podcast are not
to be taken as F aligned or's positions
and now over to our host Guillaume
reason
[Music]
welcome to the imagineer world podcast
by the future of Life Institute I'm your
host Guillaume reason
in this episode we'll be exploring a
world called Hall of Mirrors which was a
third place winner of fli's World
building contest
all of mirrors is a deeply unstable
world where nothing is as it seems the
structures of power we know today have
eroded away survive only by shells of
expectation and appearance
people are isolated by perceptual
Bubbles and struggle to agree on what's
real
despite all this things are generally
going okay for now
this is partly due to this world's
particularly slow and modest development
of AI Technologies
AI tools here are still dominated by
extensions of today's fundamentally
narrow systems with the one true AGI
being developed under heavy quarantine
there are a number of reasons for this
slow progress including high
computational costs and poor funding due
to politicization
this team put a lot of effort into
creating a plausible empirically
grounded world but their work is also
notable for its irreverence and dark
humor I can safely say that it's the
only winning world where you could see
virtual celebrity Tupac list perform at
a luxury War themed amusement park run
by the Taliban
there's a lot going on here I was
excited to get a look into the minds
behind this particularly brimming and
erratic World
Our Guest today is Michael Vasser one
member of the three-person team who
created halt mirrors Michael is a
futurist activist and entrepreneur with
an Eclectic background in Biochemistry
economics and business
he served as president of the machine
intelligence Research Institute and is
co-founder of metamed research
his other team members were Metea
Franklin a doctoral student studying AI
ethics and Alignment at University
College London and Bryce heide Smith who
has worn many hats from fortune telling
to modeling and now has a focus on
finance and policy research
hey Michael great to have you with us
great
good to speak to you
so I I'm curious how the three of you on
your team came to work on this project
together
so I've known Bryce for a very long time
and when the project was starting up
there was a call for collaborations and
I tried talking to a bunch of people
and my teacher and I had you know the
most productive conversations
but like the the overall project was
mostly my vision and matija's some level
of editing and Bryce did the fiction and
I
cool so did Bryce make the the music
that was accompanying yours yeah cool
yeah I really enjoyed your music and the
short stories as well he did a great job
with those I mean he's the closest thing
to a super intelligence that we have
around for now
adorable well what was it like for you
guys to to do this project together did
you learn anything yourself in the
course of it
I mean I had a lot of fun it helped me
to concretize some of my thinking some
I feel like the basic sense of where I
think we're going or would like to go
has been reasonably stable in my head
since gpt3 came out and hasn't
drastically changed since uh gpt2 and
covid
yeah
what were some of your biggest sources
of inspiration when you were working on
this together
I I don't think my thinking on this is
significantly influenced by stories or
books or music or what have you I think
it's basically just coming from looking
at what the technology can do and
spending the last 25 30 years
obsessively thinking event history and
the economy and social sciences and
um making some effort to understand the
technology but I'm certainly not a top
expert and actually understanding the
technology as well yeah we'll humbly
claim to be a top expert in
understanding the history of Technology
as it relates to economics yeah well you
do have this deep professional
background
um can you say a little bit about how
your experience in in other fields and
kind of working through all this
um has influenced how you see the future
I mean in terms of professional
background molecular bio I studied in
University and it doesn't really inform
this very much I have a lot of thoughts
about cool things that could be done
with molecular bile and now that gpt4 is
performing at a high school National
Championship level without major
enhancements
um I'm confident that I can do a lot
more of that stuff and also Alpha fold
is very cool and over the MRNA Tech is
very cool so I think there's enormous
opportunities now for bail
getting an MBA gave me an opportunity to
exist in the business office world for a
while and that certainly is necessary
without having interacted with corporate
hierarchies one doesn't know what
corporate hierarchies are like at all
there's very effective disinformation
and propaganda events so I think
mostly I've just read a lot in
directions that seemed like they could
be helpful over maybe a 25 30 year
period
yeah what sorts of insight did Bryce and
Vegeta bring to the project
so the actual stories were very cool and
the music was very cool and Bryce wrote
those mostly by himself
and
there were some back and forth about
what sorts of things or maybe too over
the top or too fun and silly to include
in the story
and you know it's just good to talk to
people about things and develop the
ideas together yeah and certainly Grace
has been just enormously Central to
developing my understanding of the world
in general over the last decade and what
about Matia Matia I mean mostly just
discussing what I can get away with in
terms of when telling a story what is
too weird what is
um socially acceptable enough that
people can understand it has relatively
Limited in frontal distance from
normal thoughtful people yeah
[Music]
in some ways this world is kind of a
caricature of the present we see deeper
isolation and polarization caused by
media and a proliferation of powerful
but ultimately limited AI tools that
further erode our sense to objective
reality
a deep instability threatens
and yet on a human level things seem
relatively calm
it turns out that the stories we tell
ourselves about the world have a lot of
inertia and so do the ways we live our
lives
I had a hard time picturing those
individual lives among all the wild
happenings of this world and I wanted to
hear more about that human perspective
from Michael
um what's it like to live in this world
you've made well it's going to be very
different in different media bubbles
the biggest media bubble by far is going
to be Chinese and the successor to
you know contemporary Chinese Communist
Party politics Will mean something more
neo-confusion than China has been
recently but
done with capacities that no one's ever
had the opportunity to bring to the
table so you can just spend so much more
time on filial piety and cultivating
then
when all the real work has been
automated and when you have machines
that are in some way superhuman watching
you every move and helping you along to
Express gratitude to your parents in the
most richly prescribed manner other
people have different experiences there
are probably hundreds of millions of
people trapped in pornographic universes
and effectively mind controlled by AI
that would maybe be the second largest
demographic if I really think about it
and there are lots and lots of people
like the ones we discussed at the end
living in old age homes and having their
experiences mediated through a somewhat
more tasteful
uh but still like relatively liberal and
relatively cultivated sense of
benevolence but the prospect of AGI
coming online at all
changes there in some sense these
stories were intended to point at the
extreme instability of the world that I
produced so
we have one story about producing a
piece of transhuman music and one story
about consuming it despite the cautions
of the companies around
um AGI under the you know
basically reasonable assumption that
music was not um existentially dangerous
under normal circumstances yeah so
you're referring to in your world
there's this system that deep mind has
called siren which is I think kind of
the only AGI in your world yep it's
under very tight wraps um everyone is
really carefully screened and there's
follow-up monitoring even if they just
hear the music that it produces this
system is also like written some books
on a few topics that have been carefully
curated I'm curious what broader impacts
siren's existence has on your world
given kind of how cloistered it is
I mean none by Design it's allowing it
to have more than the tiniest amount of
impact on the world would be allowing
the world to end almost immediately so
instead yeah your world really dives
into narrow AI so these are systems that
are very good at just a few specific
tasks like playing chess or driving a
car no much broader than that like the
AIS we have today like GPT which are at
least pretty good at most things that we
tend to think of as intellectual tasks
and very very very good and most things
that we tend to think of as perceptual
or as extremely rehearsed short-term
actions without a lot of context
sensitivity
I see so these are like you know
souped-up narrow AI systems they're
still not agis but they're they're kind
of a the most effective extension of
today's Technologies like chat GPT and
things like that as you're saying
they're General enough that for the vast
majority of the world's population they
probably are
vaguely thought of as generally
intelligent like the vast majority of
the world's people probably don't
understand very well
the differences between the them and
their geodes and that's probably part of
why there's essentially no funding or
work on AGI outside of device yeah
interesting and like broadly speaking
they're sufficient to produce some level
of relatively benign not totally
impenetrable but close enough uh Global
mind control system that also
contributes to not understanding the
differences and also not pursuing AGI
yeah in some ways I think that the
fiction that most my world most reminds
me of is probably Who Framed Roger
Rabbit where they have these Tunes
everywhere and the tunes control they
have personalities they have something
kind of like agency but they don't seem
too for the most part have agency with
any scale it's like an extremely very
extremely dangerous thing Fortune like
judge Doom to have agency with scale and
scope and when they do like judge Doom
it's agency with an extremely inhuman
focused skill and scope so very
potentially dangerous and the tunes are
in some sense extremely cheap and
disposable easy to produce but in some
sense Immortal and the humans are like
completely clueless about the glaring
ways in which the tomb's capabilities
are less than human such as Roger Rabbit
can only do things when it's funny
but fairly clueful about the ways in
which their abilities are more than
human like they can survive having a
piano dropped on their head I actually
haven't seen that movie but I'm really
excited now to watch it with this
metaphor in mind it's a really cool
connection yep
so one thing you say that these systems
can do in your world is basically
replace all white collar workers in
theory but you say this doesn't happen
and you say basically you know there are
various reasons political and personal
why humans are still employed I'm
curious what kinds of work humans do and
what it's like for these human workers
in this situation
so I think basically it depends on their
organization but in the pretty large
majority of organizations it's pure
office politics and
um getting therapy from not Peak human
ability but good enough AI therapists to
recover enough from the office politics
that they only kill themselves with like
drug overdoses and the like uh maybe a
third or a fourth the rate that they do
in our world
and maybe even less if AI enhanced
medicine makes such drugs significantly
less deadly and treatment significantly
more effective yeah
your world still has a ton of economic
inequality but the actual quality of
life that you describe is kind of
universally pretty good like travel has
become really cheap and there's
basically free energy and it makes food
distribution really trivials people can
kind of live wherever they want and they
have augmented reality so it'll always
look beautiful I'm curious given all of
these kind of unifying factors how
people decide where to build their lives
and what kinds of goals they decide to
pursue with them so the world that I'm
thinking of for the large majority of
people they start exploring the world
when they're children and hopefully
their parents take a lot of interest in
them but if not there's an infinite
amount of attention freely available
from the web and from open source and
Commercial products and the decisions
they make throughout their lives are
almost entirely determined by what sorts
of commercial or Open Source Products
find them first in a sense and build the
sort of feedback loops that pull them
into one or another bubble reality
you have this interesting thread in your
world where families kind of become a
currency or a kind of wealth that people
pursue more than monetary assets can you
say a little bit about what that looks
like
I mean that's just being a normal person
we've lost touch with it in you know
late stage capitalism but even under
normal capitalism this was not confusing
to anybody you know the idea of trying
to accumulate wealth rather than trying
to accumulate happy healthy wise
flourishing and mutually Cooperative
descendants
it's like a really surprising thing to
find an organism doing
so thinking about some of the the more
um unusual aspects of your world your
world definitely had some of the wildest
kind of one-off ideas in it that we saw
in the competition you have like the
Taliban creates luxury War themed
amusement parks you have elephants that
are domesticated by crispr and you even
have Kanye West creating a virtual
reproduction of biblical Jerusalem I'm
curious like what prompted these kinds
of details to be included and whether
they're part of a larger theme for you
that you were trying to convey
so the biggest thing that I left out of
the actual thing that my teacher's
influence was a coup by the comedy party
where
um basically in the 2032 election uh
between AOC and um and Donald Trump the
mainstream Democrats which still
basically control the media and the
courts decide to allow a completely
flagrant election fraud to install Jon
Stewart as a third commodity president
and you know so that one I think my
teacher thought was to
um true political too controversial but
I do think it's the sort of thing that
could realistically happen
overall where are these coming from I
mean some of them are just like
extreme low hanging fruit things that if
a few college kids could throw together
as a project and it worked with the AI
capabilities that I realistically expect
to exist well before the 2045 deadline
yeah so this is kind of just speaking to
maybe like the chaos and and the power
flying around the instability of things
and how the world is just going to get
so much stranger
yeah I don't think of it as a chaotic
world the stories are super super
non-chaotic about people living very
calm lives I see it as a world that's
very very unstable simply because it has
even one AGI in it and like
sooner or later a more permanent
solution is necessary than just keeping
its interests hyper focused and keeping
people from noticing it very much
to some degree I'm just trying to show a
picture because that's all you can do in
a story like this but a picture where
all of the pieces are scientifically
well-founded technologically
economically and politically
well-founded makes sense and fit
together fairly well
I guess more than anything else I'm
trying to show people like the contest
is trying to show people that it is even
possible to make a sincere serious and
competent effort to depict a realistic
but optimistic future
[Music]
thank you
major changes are hacking away at the
foundations of this world's systems the
loss of shared reality and weakening of
governmental structures at least in the
west seem to strip Humanity of a good
deal of agency
it's implied that we're being kept from
destruction only by our tenuous control
of this world's one true AGI
at the same time new approaches to
things like education and social
conflict signal hope for building a more
coherent and empowered Humanity
I wanted to hear more about how Michael
saw this world approaching the changes
and challenges that it faced
you write that in America like Microsoft
Amazon Tesla and Walmart are basically
the only entities capable of large-scale
coordinated action anymore and elected
government officials really just enact
change by influencing their supporters
rather than by pursuing any kind of
legislation most decisions are made
locally can you say a little bit more
about how America's governmental systems
lose so much influence in your world
so I just see that as a continuation of
the trend that we're already on when you
look at covid the government took an
unbelievably huge amount of oppressive
and authoritarian action that there
probably won't be social or political
support for if there's another major
event that calls for it it lost an
enormous amount of public Trust
and if you look at what the government
did that was effective with co-fed it
basically boils down to printing
enormous amounts of money
and providing certain types of
encouragement to conform to a certain
standard so like it's not that the
government no longer matters it's just
that it like popularity contests should
be is primarily a source of information
about how to be popular but just like an
orbital people mostly want to be popular
if they don't want it as much as a noble
because they can always be popular with
their eyes but still AIS are not fully
satisfying as mental and social
companions
well as this power kind of switches over
and flows towards tech companies gaining
influence it becomes increasingly hard
to track wealth but in some ways it also
seems like things are just kind of going
on sheer inertia you have this great
line in your submission that says a
super majority of the population has
negative net worth and continues to be
allocated credit as a matter of economic
policy and you mentioned this kind of
instability of the world how long do you
see it remaining stable like will these
systems fall apart shortly after 2045
and you're imagining her
so the way I'm imagining this this is a
fairly close to best case scenario my
realistic uh best guess scenario would
be that it's more than 70 likely maybe
more than 80 likely that the system that
I'm describing falls apart well before
it gets to the point that I'm describing
but these are supposed to be optimistic
missions for the future
but once it gets to the point that I'm
describing if it gets to that point I
actually imagine it being stable for a
pretty long time
I mean except for the energy item yeah
siren gets out
one one big tension in your world as a
result of this increasing difficulty and
verifying information is just people
have a hard time agreeing on objective
reality like they're really good in
experimental Healthcare interventions
but it's mostly kind of about luck and
maybe some skill to pick the winners out
of that crowd you have cryptocurrency
that's made it really impossible to tell
how much money anyone has like you
mentioned that instead of Forbes keeping
track of wealth now kidnapping Rings
keep some of the best records of
people's total assets and you even say
that startups are buying these records
off of those kidnapping rings to find
wealthy funders so can you say a little
bit more about what leads to this like
deep fracturing of shared objectivity
so I mean that's been going on really in
a big way since the 1940s and once again
I'm just imagining it continuing and
accelerating with more powerful
Technologies
um the collapse of the dollar which
happens in the 2030s more or less in my
story
contribute to fair amount it makes the
crypto thing much more substantial
and the increase like basically social
welfare through uh senior Edge and the
expansion of senior Edge through the
population
helps to stabilize things a lot at the
expensive coherence and deficiency which
isn't really necessarily anymore could
you say what senior Ridge is senior age
is printing money but through bank
activities when Banks borrow money then
they lend out much more money and like
there's a stack of different interest
rates paid by different Predators so the
one of the basic challenges of running a
capitalist Society that's been well
understood since long before Adam Smith
is the extreme difficulty of causing
control of the money printing apparatus
to not be the convergent agenda of
practically everyone
and most capitalist societies do
collapse as control of the money
printing apparatus becomes a convergent
agenda so I'm basically Imagining the
essential worker system that we
discovered we had during covid and the
relatively resilient management of a
small number of companies basically
keeping the material reality held
together despite the fact that the vast
majority of supposed economic activity
is actually pure uh political wealth
redistribution uh to the people who
bother to fight for wealth being
distributed to them in a world where
most people have basically lost track of
wealth anyway yeah
I'm curious why AI systems don't help
more with these issues of like shared
goals and shared knowledge I mean you
mentioned that ERI systems can provide
common knowledge like they help groups
of people identify if their behaviors
are aligned with their goals or how to
change their behavior so they would be
you would think that that might kind of
cut through the haze and help people you
know agree on things more or have more
transparency
I mean AI systems help enormously with
establishing whatever set of goals is
reasonably psychologically plausible and
that the systems designers want to
establish but mostly that consists of
like
consuming products just like it does in
our world and in the rare cases of
societies that have more of a shared set
of values and more of a shared power
structure like China it means that they
have incredibly High integration and
unity targeting shared goals that more
or less consist of normal reasonable
things like extending life and
ecological sustainability and stability
in general
one other thread I really enjoyed in
your world is how you talk about
education changing so people start to
see traditional educational pedigrees as
a form of inherited privilege and
educational histories actually become
private information which can't be used
in decisions like hiring which is a
really interesting concept and this tips
the scales in favor of online
self-driven education schools basically
go empty while kids live with their
families and learn on their own I'm
curious what this looks like for those
kids like what are they learning what
aren't they learning and who's deciding
so I'm basically imagining that
nominally the parents decide when the
kids are younger and the kids decide
when they're older but in practice
reasonably authentic parents who are
also tech savvy and have like reasonably
coherent preferences about
what to get
will will be able to direct their kids
towards media Bubbles and you know
narratives that will be extremely stable
and which won't change much unless
something really weird happens
so
I expect that almost everyone's learning
speed is going to be like
at least four or five times faster
between more targeted instruction
objectively better instruction uh maybe
learning enhancement through drugs and
mRNA Tech
and much better trauma care is a major
feature of my world so just the
elimination of mental blocks through
MDMA therapies and their successors
I don't know if I really played up
adequately the spread of a new way of
doing civilization from the carceral
system into the general population as
like MDMA therapies get adopted for
dispute resolution within prisons and
reach a level of
reliability and efficacy that's
sufficient that basically everyone wants
some
[Music]
despite some of the more mad cap details
of their world this team expresses a
strong commitment to realism and
plausibility
their portrayal of AI development was
also perhaps the slowest and most
restricted among our winners
while there is an AGI around most of the
technological developments in this world
are just extensions of today's narrow AI
systems it was awesome capabilities are
ultimately Limited I was curious to hear
more about this team's creative
influences and whether the slower pace
of AI development was something they saw
as merely likely or a necessary
component of any safe path to an
aspirational future
so I'd like to spend a little while
discussing the the narratives in your
world and how they compare to other
narratives that are going around in
popular culture like one really big
through line for me is this sort of
Emperor has no close attitude you have
towards economics and politics where
your world kind of just goes through the
motions to keep things moving along but
the systems themselves are no longer
really doing much I'm curious if there
are other examples of this perspective
that inspired you in other kinds of
media
I mean mostly I'm inspired by real life
and I'll find media and narratives I
can't think of a piece of fiction that
is as radical as real life in the degree
to which it violates conventional
assumptions you know it's basically
impossible to do without being a top
tier literary genius like Shakespeare I
mean Hamlet's wonderful Doris lessig's
book The Golden notebook is maybe the
best depiction I've ever seen But one
would need to be a really really good
literary scholar to appreciate it I
think same with Hamlet interesting
oh I'm curious if there are any examples
and this this can come from you know
philosophers as well as fiction of
economic or political systems that could
actually maybe function in a world like
yours or do you think that the whole
concept of having a system that's run in
a sensible way is kind of moot
no I mean the Chinese system is sort of
run in a sensible way in the world I'm
describing it's not run with perfect
rigor and resolution it wouldn't pass
like talmudic standards but by the
standards that we're used to from
government I the I'm imagining a China
with a life expectancy of well over 100
years and a the ability to industrially
produce in a clean way and with very
little labor practically everything the
entire world needs
the um
goals of maximizing filial pod and where
no just going to be what's inherited
from their ancestors and traditions and
it may not seem like doing a thing to us
but
you know most of what we do
is arguably not really doing a thing
do you think there are any any actions
or reforms we could do to Western
systems that would make them more
resilient to these changes as well
I mean my simple answer is I already put
them all into this story that's why the
world is still alive yeah and has not
collapsed already I I involve you know
I'm making a number of
surprising good luck happens assumptions
not extraordinary I I really try to keep
avoid endorsing things that are not just
quirky and that have probabilities of
less than about 10 percent
you know I think it's important to note
that our world would be way scarier to
people from my vision of 2045 then there
will be from us interesting there would
just be like incredibly addictive and we
would very quickly find ourselves
trapped in some relatively exploitative
bubble but even exploitative bubbles
have reasons to try to keep people
mentally healthy enough to keep on
receiving government benefits within a
thin veneer of contributing to the
economy I guess one way to think about
it is the American dream is basically a
collage of the America prior to the
Civil War America between the Civil War
and the New Deal and America after the
New Deal which could be summarized as
the colonist experience the Immigrant
experience and the GI experience and
none of these experiences at all
resemble what Zoomers are coming into
and experiencing and so they are growing
up in a world of such transparent lies
that their almost without exception
total epistemic nihilist mistakenly
disbelieved that anything was ever true
rather than only disbelieving that
anything that they've ever seen is true
which is the actually the case
so one really unique thing about your
world is this focus on the narrow AI
systems and how high a ceiling you put
on their abilities you kind of have
basically a suite of different narrow AI
systems that together have the
capabilities of an AGI in some ways but
they're spread across these separate
modules no they don't have the
capabilities of an AGI they don't have
anything even remotely close to the
abilities of nature yeah so can you
distinguish that the story is just kind
of hinting at the capabilities of an AGI
with the sort of security around it and
the sort of implied impact and like
potential risk so I'm operating with the
definition of AGI that's something like
a system that's better than a human at
any task that you can reasonably Define
is that different from what you say when
you say that these narrow AI systems no
they're better than any human at any
task that you can reasonably Define I'm
saying that the the systems that I'm
describing are not even remotely close
to that they're like superhuman at very
narrow tasks at like a they're
superhuman at all lot of very narrow
tasks
but but it doesn't even come close
fitting them all together to the full
range of human capabilities I see so
there's kind of a Synergy here you're
saying right and then there are like
not superhuman but like merely as good
as the experts that top Elites tend to
point to
at the vast majority of tasks that um
get measured and graded and systematized
and standardized throughout Society so
the best doctors in my world are still
humans who make very heavy use of AI
tools but the
best purely AI doctors might only be as
good as the doctors that like the
president has in our world but not
nearly as good as the doctors that like
a top doctor has in our world since the
top doctors know who their actual best
doctors are and to date them so not only
do these systems not exceed the best
human experts individually at these
narrower tasks but you're also saying
that there's there's something missing
even if you have this collection of
narrow systems that can each do
something that a human can do just
putting those together is not the same
as having something that could do all of
these flexibly is that what you're
saying definitely but also there are
things that none of them can do even a
little bit like in the story that I'm
talking about siren is the only only AI
in the world that could could if it
wanted to do important original
mathematics it's the only AI in the
world that could if it wanted to make
the tiniest contribution to theoretical
or applied physics
so in your world you have this
incredibly powerful AGI system that does
exist but it's under really really
strong protections under tight wraps
um do you think this is necessary to
have a optimistic future with AGI in it
yeah definitely unless we can basically
do you know
that was interviewer's worth of
philosophical progress in like
20 years
and we can't like maybe we can do
thousands interviews with the
philosophical progress this Century
because we will have both Ai and other
Technologies for enhancing our mental
capabilities if we choose to use them
but we can't do it in 20 years it's just
laughable yeah
so the limitations that are preventing
AGI from developing faster in your world
some of them are intentional like policy
decisions some of them are just kind of
practical ones like bad funding
politicization and the Rarity of human
expertise do you think these are actual
likely causes of slowing development in
the real world
yeah that's my my best guess is that AGI
progress much more slowly than I have it
progressing in my story and my best
guess is that
we do survive because AGI progresses
much more slowly from my perspective
it's extremely contrived for a GI to be
to develop even as fast as it does in
this story and be handled well enough
cautiously enough thoughtfully enough
that like
we have more than a fraction of a
percent chance of survival yeah
have you seen other portrayals of the
future where narrow AI plays as much of
a role as in yours
I mean I feel like there's a lot of
portrayals of the future where narrow AI
is taken for granted and plays a large
role like in Star Trek the Next
Generation they have one AGI data like
in my world and then they have like
unbelievably powerful narrow Ai and the
ship and in the Holodeck and it was just
all over the place but everyone takes it
for granted and it's used as a tool by a
military organization with a relatively
unified internal agenda of exploration
and extremely prudish and narrow
conceptions of
what types of experiences and behaviors
it members are supposed to engage in
I will say that the narrow the type of
narrow AI that we
we have actually developed
is like
pretty broad compared to what I expected
five years ago it's like very much what
we were visibly moving towards four
years ago
but to some degree when I was growing up
C-3PO seemed like a silly fantasy it
seemed silly that you could have a
machine that was that close to
Human Performance but like stuck for a
long time uh below Human Performance and
in some ways pretty profoundly below and
in some ways pretty profoundly
superhuman but like just be stuck there
for a long time
but it kind of looks from the
technologies that opening AI is
generating that a minimum viable C-3PO
might actually happen and be around for
a long time without really drastic
improvement from there
how do you feel about the general
portrayals of the future that are in
fiction do you think they're over or
under optimistic when they try to be
optimistic
and just think optimism in fiction that
is trying to be at all realistic
is unfortunately much rarer
than it should be and like that's
basically maybe largely because the most
perceptive and
insightful people
who are also successful at becoming
prominent and surrounding themselves
with other prominent people
are constantly confronted with lots of
profoundly miserable
um extremely Zero Sum other prominent
people and have very little contact with
the large majority of people who are
just not as miserable yes the people who
like Nobel laureates are going to end up
around
so you're kind of calling for more
optimism in non-fiction as well is that
where you're going
I mean no I feel like optimism and
pessimism is like intrinsically
unhealthy Concepts you should just try
to have true beliefs but
true beliefs should be balanced like
there's a lot of social pressure
to performatively be pessimistic because
the elites tend to be pessimistic
and Elites tend to be pessimistic
because they're living in a
hyper-competitive zero-sum world that
most of us are not living in
and there's a lot of it's easier in some
ways to be pessimistic especially
cheaply pessimistic but there's also
like just cognitive biases that lead to
silly sorts of pessimism so like imagine
there was a news item about how it turns
out that apples cause cancer
practically everyone would see this as
bad news oh no I've been poisoning
myself for years but obviously it's good
news we know what the cancer rate is
yeah now we know that we can avoid it by
not eating apples right the devil you
know
like information is almost always
desirable
but information about bad things gets
interpreted as something bad happening
rather than being interpreted as
something good happening you know James
Baldwin uh not everything that can be
confronted can be overcome but
everything to be overcome must be
confronted
and to some degree my this picture that
I'm depicting is an edge case on that
because this is a world that has managed
to
partially overcome and fully survive a
lot of the problems that our society is
dying from Without Really confronting
them
in your world a lot of the role models
become virtual so basically all
celebrities popular with the under 30
crowd are virtual people summer
Recreations of historical figures others
are kind of amalgams like Tupac lists
and you have xxxtentacion Elvis XXX I'm
curious how these play a role as kind of
uh role models in your world
I think they mostly don't I think that
people who have at least reasonably good
taste do prefer interaction with
individuals insofar as they mostly
imitate Behavior by
um real people
and that like the social influences from
machines are in general more of a you
know goal-directed relatively overt
manipulation sort
what are your thoughts on some of the
current cultural attitudes towards like
AI generated art and virtual cultural
figures right now so it seems like any
reasonably good artist wants to make oh
not wants to get paid for making art and
like maybe wants to be seen and people
can worry that a lot of people will
never be exposed to good or because
they're going to be exposed to an
enormous amount of stuff that doesn't
have a message behind it and isn't
created as an expression of pain and
suppressed emotion but like if you're a
good artist you can learn new tools and
you keep learning new tools throughout
your life and you learn how to make use
of these new tools to compete and to get
your message out there the
barriers to entry for art in some sense
never go down because they have to do
with the attention and consciousness of
your audience the economic barriers to
entry in our world
are going up because of extreme economic
scarcity that's being created through
policy so like we're living in a time of
really extreme economic conservity
compared to the Great Depression at this
point we've lost way more actual
economic freedom in the sense of like
not needing to work very hard or very
well would be very exceptional in order
to afford
to reproduce our own labor have children
and grandchildren and have them live at
least as nicely as we do and be able to
purchase our baskets of goods and every
Zoomer knows it because like they in
fact can't purchase the baskets of goods
that their parents had and their parents
deny them recognition as adults even
even like Millennials with kids or
denied recognition as adults in major
ways because they don't have the baskets
of consumption Goods that in fact
generationally speaking they can't have
thank you
the process of World building has great
potential to make a positive future feel
more attainable
this can be incredibly powerful whether
you're a creative person looking to
produce Rich works of fiction or have a
more technical focus and are looking to
reach policy makers or the public
I asked Michael what kind of impacts he
hoped his work would have on the world
what do you hope your world leaves
people thinking about long after they've
read through it
so the biggest thing is that I just
would like people to try to make sense
of what could happen I would like them
to know that it is possible
to make a joint prediction and
expression of preference that is in line
with like the relatively full range of
scientific and technological and
humanistic thinking and that holds
together and makes sense and that like
much more close to comes true and also
somewhat guides Society towards it
coming true
then what we would normally think of as
science fiction what kinds of expertise
would you be most interested in having
people bring to discussions about your
world or the future in general
the things that I would want to bring in
first would be
somatic skills like body work and yoga
and things like that
experience with MDMA and other
psychedelic Therapies
and maybe even electrical engineering
for creating better alternatives to
transcranial magnetic stimulation for uh
disinhibiting some parts of the cortex
and activating other parts of the cortex
so that so to enable people to recapture
usually after years of work
the thoughts of cognitive abilities that
like normal smart inquisitive kids had
when I was a kid
in which the entire literary imprint of
Western Civilization is the imprint of
which is why we don't have a literary
imprint for our contemporary
civilization
do you have any particular hopes about
the impacts that this work would have on
the younger generation of folks around
today
it seems to me that the vast majority of
Zoomers
are doomers they believe that the world
is going to hell in a hand basket and
everything is falling apart
but they are likewise cynics in that
about the past in that they somehow
believe that things have been getting
worse forever but we're never better
than they are today and that that can't
be a concrete set of beliefs it it
actually has to be something that they
have instead of having beliefs which is
like a posture A vibe and you know
what's actually going on is that they
have always been lied to about
everything of importance by every
credible Authority so they like don't
believe that people can know things
and they can only know believe that
people can posture and Vibe that's
really sad because manifestly the world
around us displays incredible amounts of
the results of knowledge and if people
don't continue to produce the results of
that knowledge we're going to live in a
much less nice world
what could help to correct for this or
influence their attitudes in a positive
way for you
well
to a really non-trivial degree
large language models you know that we
have today if they were reinforcement
learning trained for questioning and
challenging and calling out
and especially for perceiving the
emotional dynamics of social situations
which are very easy to proceed for even
average humans and wouldn't be that hard
to train systems to perceive
like people need social support in
calling out rather than all of
the social pressure
being to submit to and go along
with it and like we have the technology
today
to build
artificial social support of precisely
the type we need
what aspects of your world would you be
most excited to see popular media take
on when portraying the future
well just don't having a picture of
China as something like China rather
than than using China as our designated
bad guy which we use to project the
images of ourselves basically our
popular media almost exclusively treats
China as a scapegoat for the types of
behavior that we are very aware that we
engage in to approximately the same
degree that they do
and is almost always trying to display
you know
bias for the sake of showing loyalty
rather than trying to display
scholarship and understanding
I think that
that in general a somewhat more balanced
View
of all sorts of cultural things having
more of an attitude that most things
have a good have some good and some bad
in them
well thanks so much for joining us today
Michael we've covered so much ground in
this conversation and it's been really
great to explore all these ideas with
you
it's um great having this conversation
[Music]
this podcast has got you thinking about
the future you can find out more about
this world and explore the ideas
contained in the other worlds at
www.worldbuild.ai
we want to hear your thoughts are these
worlds you'd want to live in
if you've enjoyed this episode and would
like to help more people discover and
discuss these ideas you can give us a
rating or leave a comment wherever
you're listening to this podcast you
read all the comments and appreciate
every rating this podcast is produced
and edited by worldview studio and the
future of Life Institute
I as a non-profit that works to reduce
large-scale risks from transformative
Technologies and promote the development
and use of these Technologies to benefit
all life on Earth we run educational
Outreach and grants programs and
advocate for better policy making in the
United Nations U.S government and
European Union institutions if you're a
Storyteller working on Films or other
creative projects about the future we
can also help you understand the science
and storytelling potential of
transformative Technologies
touch with us or any of the teams
featured on the podcast to collaborate
you can email World build at
futureoflife.org
a reminder this podcast explores the
ideas created as part of fli's World
building contest and our hope is that
this series Sparks discussion about the
kinds of Futures we all want
the ideas we discuss here are not to be
taken as fli positions
you can find more about our work at
www.futureoflife.org or subscribe to our
newsletter to get updates on all our
projects
thanks for listening to imagine a world
stay tuned to explore more positive
futures
thank you